uh switching focus now we've been uh
hearing from the mayor of mariopol uh
vadim boychenko who's been giving an
online briefing about the humanitarian
situation uh in the city and uh let's
listen to what the mayor of mary paul
had to say just moments ago
the situation remains dire as it has
been but the city remains ukrainian
our heroic defenders are fighting
holding out with incredible valor and
bravery
defending the city of mario by defending
our future defending our homeland
ukraine and this has to be made very
clear
their plight is
very difficult because they are vastly
outnumbered
it's very difficult for them to hold out
when they say they're made of steel
we should also know that steel also has
its breaking points but they are holding
out at the city of mariupol remains a
ukrainian city it is also a difficult
situation because of the humanitarian
catastrophe
created by the russian invasions and
their collaborators from the opposition
bloc
as
they have destroyed the critical
infrastructure in the town there's no
running water no electricity no cell
coverage and add russian propaganda on
top of that that russia's resort to
this happened at a time when the
residents had no information whatsoever
we started attempted evocation from the
very first days of march but the
invaders didn't want to leave out any
people they
would intentionally and deliberately
shoot the meeting places they destroyed
all the buses that we planned to use for
the evacuation purposes in 10 days
they
reduced all of that to ashes the
evacuation was never enabled because the
enemy thwarted all our efforts
meanwhile our residents
attempted
evacuation of their private vehicles and
the armed forces did relieve them
outside the city but they would only
travel to the first checkpoint
with a russian flag flying over it and
they'd be told the following
we haven't received an order to allow
passage for any residents or mighty uber
they would have to take a u-turn and
this russian propaganda would add to the
message that you've been abandoned
they've left you
and only on the 13th of april where the
whole world coalesced around evacuation
from madrupal the evacuation was enabled
with private vehicles when the enemy
troops
opened the passage through their
checkpoints and people have been able to
leave the city traveling to berlin
zapudia and from beijing
they've traveled onwards so this has
finally happened then and now
there
about
150 000 people have been able to leave
marijuana into ukraine controlled
territories there are over a hundred
thousand people staying in my room but
120 000 people are staying in my opinion
there are also people in the outskirts
wanting to evacuate that's another 60
000 people so we keep urging every day
every morning to the entire global
community that we need to stand together
to liberate marijuana to evacuate the
innocent civilians from marijuana
the
marijuana stands at as long as it stands
our country shall stand
earlier some negotiations with france
greece turkey when progress about the
international humanitarian missions to
marijuana has any progress been made in
these negotiations what came out of
these negotiations about the
international humanitarian missions
we have to make it clear that the
russian federation does not
seek to support any international
mission and we know clearly why that is
so either red cross or a turkish mission
or any other mission like a french
measure they tried to intervene
they would come to the city and witness
firsthand the atrocities abominably
created by the russian troops the
destroyed hospitals
dozens of
dead corpses
the raised drama theater hospital
burned to ashes
with
heavily injured residents of mariupol
who stayed inside at that point this is
a war this is a genocide of the
russian-speaking population of marijuana
this is the war
that was launched by a war criminal
putin
against our society our nation and the
only he has succeeded in his special
operation is raising the city of mario
destroying the ukrainian population of
marupo that he succeeded in
we lost the connection with um
mr boychenko
please gone
we can hear you now
we're trying to regain the connection
we lost the signal unfortunately
let's wait we hear the tragic news from
mariupol as we heard from
vice prime minister very shook there'll
be no humanitarian corridors operating
in ukraine today
and let us test out the connection
okay we can hear you fine
please carry on
and we have more questions for you in
store
we have lost that signal again we are
working to reconnect
the um
vice prime minister irena varischuk
reported that there will be no
evacuation corridors in operation today
as
the mayor of madrupal has told us
earlier that people have not been able
to leave mario by driving their own cars
i'm passing the floor to the journalist
we have a question in here you will hear
it interpreted over to you
greek national television ert
do you have evidence
that russian forces dropped chemicals on
mariupol and is it true that they
brought mobile crematoriums
firstly about the war crimes
that have been evidenced in marijuana
the first crime committed on the night
of
march when the russian war plane dropped
two bombs on a maternity ward in mario
pal where the residents
died
women and children
the second war crime was committed on
the 16th of march in mariupol when
another enemy a plane dropped two bombs
on the mario drama theater and there are
many such war crimes that have been
documented we documented
the fact of raising our town 40 percent
of the multi-story building have been
reduced to rubble they're past any
repair and this is a
this is uh pertaining to
the majority of people in mario pal we
have the video records photographic
evidence that are now collected by the
relevant uh
agencies of our country and these are
war crimes the day before yesterday the
russian troops attempted
to
strike our city with a chemical attack
they tried to drop the chemical
agent on our defenders the agent did
affect our defenders a few people in the
outskirts of mariupol were also affected
they sensed the sweet
taste in their mouth
this
warned
them
in the
towns and villages around mariupol and
people started fleeing
from these outskirts of marijuana
because they sensed danger
there's no way to
collect evidence of that a lab would
need to do the analysis to
[Music]
to make the finding about the enemy
troops and the donetsk
proxies of russia
have
stated that they intend to deploy the
chemical agents because they cannot
defeat our defenders who are defending
this city and they were the first to
allege that they had committed the
crime
before that information was available
that
there allegedly some chemical labs in
the city developing
some chemical agents or weapons
and we knew that they were planning to
launch this attack and this
unfortunately has happened
you